well I haven't yet decided whether or
not to make the birth there's no way
I'll vote for a remainder Theresa May
was a remainer
her heart was never in leaving what she
filed and in the end I'm afraid dr.
ferral
well she the party lost confidence in
her and so did the house of God as
Theresa May stands down as British Prime
Minister all eyes are on the contest to
succeed her with Boris Johnson currently
leading the pack my guest this week here
in London is the Conservative MP mark
Francois from the hardline European
research group that's been snapping
endlessly around mrs. Mays heels but
with the Conservative Party's ratings
currently plummeting through the floor
thus the party even deserve to survive
[Music]
[Music]
what Francois welcome to comforting son
hello your party has scored its worst
election result in its history in the
European elections dire warnings that
the party is going to collapse can't
unite can't compromise can't govern it's
time it collapsed isn't it no it's time
it picked a new leader and that's what
we're going to do mrs. may resigns as
leader of the Conservative Party on
Friday and we then have a process to
pick a new leader in essence the members
of parliament there are 313 conservative
embodies at present we vote to narrow it
down to two candidates and then the
party members will vote so by the end of
July they will pick in a postal ballot
one of those two candidates who will
then become the Prime Minister at some
point the Prime Minister will probably
have to win a vote of confidence in the
House of Commons probably realistically
in the autumn which if it's a hard-line
brexit area you'll lose well I doubt it
there's no appetite in Parliament for No
Deal well personally I think I don't
think we have to have no deal I think we
can go one better so why not sign the
deal then it's already on the deal is
dead as a dodo and it's been turned down
three times by the House of Commons the
first defeat was the biggest defeat any
British government has ever suffered in
the entire history of Parliament going
back hundreds of years so the deal is
never going to go through and the reason
the deal was defeated is because I've
read it it's a 585 you've read all 580
fact yes twice and that's my job I'm a
member of parliament and it isn't in
effect to draft international treaty so
what do you think you can get the
problem with the so called withdrawal
agreements in a nutshell is that we
didn't withdraw we still remain because
of the backstop in a customs union we
wouldn't have run around trade policy we
could've done international trade deals
with America or China or Brazil the
European Court of Justice would still
have power hosting the transition period
well just in the transition people
no because the arbitration period lasts
beyond that if you look at article 174
and also there will be a number of other
areas like the Joint Committee which
lasts beyond the transition period which
by which two civil servants effectively
could make law above the head of
Parliament so mr. falsify the the deal
provides for an exit from Europe's
political union and it's institutions
true or false
isn't that what you wanted no that is
not true because it's still that so for
instance the Joint Committee still means
political control so look the deal is -
the deal is dead well so what do you do
well what you do is you accept that the
deal is dead and you say can we do
better than no deal in fact we can so
what you do is you go straight to the
so-called future relationship and you
say what is the desired end state at the
end of all of these negotiations and
that is a comprehensive free trade
agreement between the United Kingdom and
the European Union so that we can trade
to our mutual benefit an advantage with
low or no tariffs into the foreseeable
future we were always going to have to
at some point agree the future
relationship so my argument would be
cultural markets and well let
manufacturing that market well that's a
matter for negotiation but there is an
existing template it's the EU Canadian
free-trade agreement which was signed in
2016 how many years well that took seven
years to negotiate it but the advantage
of that is is that we've already done
all the heavy lifting
so we've argued they argue heavy lifting
it's a very different economy but what
you would do very different well but
what you do is you take that as a start
point so you have a template that you
know by definition the EU did accept
because they signed it and then you so
you don't start with the blank piece of
paper you start with the hats and then
you see whether you can modify it so for
instance it would be well yes and I'm
perfectly prepared to leave on WTO terms
while those negotiations take place but
I would have spite the fact that
industry is warning that this is
project fear nonsense well you could say
your project fantasy well you don't know
well well the European election the
European elections in this country or
overwhelmingly won by the brexit party
whose policy was to leave if necessary
with No Deal the people in this country
overwhelmingly voted for that so there
is a mandate but what I'm saying is
you're not saying there's a majority of
people in this country who wanted No
Deal
because because there's nothing to
suggest that well hang on as a matter of
fact the European elections were clearly
won by the party the turnout of 37
percent mr. Francois that's not a
majority of the British people is it off
forgive me but the majority to leave in
the 2016 referendum a seventeen point
four million British people voted that's
the biggest vote we've ever had in this
country on any proposition ever in our
entire history as a nation can we just
talk about the leaders because I know
you're going to see Boris Johnson after
this is this somebody you can support as
Prime Minister and leader but I haven't
yet decided whether or not to vote for
Boris that's partly what I'm talking
about but you would consider it well I
will vote for brexit air there's no way
I will vote for a remainder Theresa May
was a remainer
her heart was never in leaving she
always saw it as a kind of damage and
imitation exercise well you say that she
said she was quite good concern to
deliver brexit she promised on
innumerable occasions to deliver
breakfast she failed and in the end I'm
afraid you had to fail
well she the party lost confidence in
there and so did the House of Commons
you happy that Boris Johnson has been
ordered to appear in court but claims
that he lied during the referendum
over this 350 million pounds a week to
the well the person who's done those is
an absolute ardent remainer and actually
if they that matter well yes of course
it it doesn't have a bearing on the well
it does because clearly he's doing it
from a particular perspective if the aim
is to damage Boris it will have
precisely the opposite effect because
remember the decision on who to pick
will go to our members and if they see
him being hounded in the courts by an
arch Romania they're more likely to vote
for him
so actually you you you undermining
public faith in the courts you don't
think the courts will reach the right
decision I mean
the judge was quite clear I am satisfied
there is sufficient to establish prima
facie evidence of an issue to be
determined at trial well I would argue
that the place to argue politics is in
Parliament not in a courtroom
it's arguing whether the charges are in
essence that he deliberately mislead
voters these are allegations of
misconduct in public office I think is
important well I don't believe he did
but he will make us all decide that well
but I as I say it's a politically
motivated charge by an ardent remainer
and what it will do is it will probably
boost Boris vote among Tory party
members that the courts are independent
will reach an independent decision and
in any case the figure was absurd it was
label absurd by the Institute of Fiscal
Studies and misleading by the UK
statistics well actually we're not using
it well the Conservative government has
now announced a twenty billion pounds a
year cash injection into the National
Health Service under what's known as the
NHS ten year plan so that will actually
more than cover the three hundred and
fifty million pound figure yeah well
actually end up spending whenever Nigel
Faraj who used that figure during the
referendum campaign admitted that it
simply wasn't true well if it let us see
what the arguments are knew it wasn't
true you've been a minister you know
that 350 million wasn't true why didn't
you call it out at all what excuse me
let's see what the court decides when
they debated but at the end of the day
you're not answering my question
well well knew it was false no you
didn't know it was the great it was the
correct brosef figure there was an
argument there wasn't soldiers of grouse
well there was an argument about whether
you used a grouse figure or net figure
as a gross figure it was literally true
and I'm sure Boris would make that point
in court
viruses has a history of being
economical with the truth isn't he he
told Britons after the referendum that
they would still have access to the
single market that turned out to be
nonsense well I'm not here as an
advocate for Boris Johnson you said you
might vote for him well I said I might
but I suggest you go and ask to
interview Boris Johnson as he's not here
perhaps you'd like to interview me I'm
interviewing you about what you thought
what you thought about Boris was I say
I'm gonna go and talk to him after this
I'm afraid your cameras won't be present
to that
the country wanted this bill that you've
said is dead in the water this with did
Milton well what do you base that the
opinion polls which opinion well okay
March the 29th YouGov poll those who
voted leave in 2016 the outcome which
you supported these same people wanted
to see that deal pass by 49% to 30%
conservative voters asked on the same
day wanted by an even higher amount of
margin to get this deal over the line
57% to 24% if you didn't care what they
thought is it any wonder they don't care
what you think won't vote for your party
let me give you another YouGov poll
which was prior to that which said that
54% of the public did not believe that
the withdrawal agreement represented
leaving the EU 14% 1/4 did but they
still wanted it passed didn't they on
the 29th of March poll same people that
voted leave wanted it passed bar 49 to
30% have you read the majority why do
you need me to fill you it well I've
read it so I know what's in it do you I
don't need to in other words with in
other words you don't know I don't need
to in other words draw but you don't
know what so it doesn't matter whether I
know does it well I do because I've read
it and that's why I voted the interstate
I'm talking about the polls with respect
you're trying to lecture me on an
agreement and you haven't perhaps you
like to do this interview again when
you've read the withdraw degree people
were because you would be much better
informed people were asked a very simple
question the 2016 referendum were they
should the UK remain a member of the
European Union or leave the European
Union that was the question that was on
the ballot they didn't vote for a proper
brexit or an ERG brixi there were no
deal brexit in fact on that particular
issue vote leave was pretty clear there
wouldn't be a no deal outcome wasn't it
well as I was trying to argue earlier I
think that the best outcome is not an
ideal outcome it's a free trade
agreement out there but why is it that
you to clean the ERG in this part of a
conservative party of set yourself up as
the arbiters of what
really means because the withdrawal
agreement doesn't achieve brexit and
therefore we want something that does we
want to leave the European Union we want
to be a sovereign nation we want to
elect our own government and make our
own laws and at the end of the day
there's someone who can kind a lot in
the referendum that was the critical
issue there were a number of issues
applying that money was an issue
immigration was an issue but the
overriding issue was sovereignty it was
about who governs who makes our laws who
governs our way of life and the British
people voted by a majority of well over
a million votes that we wanted to take
back control of our own destiny and our
own government that's really what brexit
means on the 31st of October that is
precisely what we're going to do let's
talk a bit about the nature of the
political discourse in Britain at the
moment what happened to compromise in
British politics and I ask this because
this issue has helped to turn Britain
into a pretty angry and divided country
hasn't it you and your colleagues often
seem to revel in there why well I
wouldn't use the word wrath all but the
truth is is that the British
establishment and my meaning I included
maps and powerful officials in number 10
Downing Street and in the catalyst
office I include a number of many
members of parliament I include some in
the media though not yourself sir who
have never accepted the result of the
referendum who thought that people were
wrong and who spent three years doing
their best to frustrate their decision
so it's a conspiracy it's them and us
it's it's the people versus the
establishment as you wrote as you wrote
in that is exactly what it is and on in
the European elections the people won
and your expression of fellow travelers
which you also put in your eyes will
suggest a whiff of Cold War treachery
why the apocalyptic language that you
and your colleagues are using bill cash
one of your senior members accused
Teresa may of appeasement a forced and
humiliating surrender former Foreign
Office knows that Alistair Burke
criticized the use of words like
mendacity surrender betrayal
does it ever cross your mind he said to
bill cash what you're contributing to
and the answer is a toxic
febrile environment well the Sun
newspaper and the Telegraph newspaper
analyzed the withdrawal agreement when
it was published
they both their words not mine described
it as a surrender so you might want to
take it up with the editor of the son or
the editor of The Daily Telegraph yeah
but you don't need to parent what the
son says or the Daily Telegraph
no the my point is is that they were
using that language their national
newspapers yeah so do you do set your
compass by what the national newspapers
do on the country you said there are
people in the press you don't want to
follow who are part of this conspiracy
well I've read the module agreement and
it is a surrender document that's why I
would never vote for it isn't the
country divided enough without people
pouring more oil on the fire painting
them and us scenarios like you do
talking of conspiracies when the other
side the people who oppose your view
just think differently that's it they
think different they're allowed to think
differently in the democracy and of
course they are but equally it's
important to remember that before the
referendum of the government spent 9
million pounds of British taxpayers
money sending a leaflet through every
door in the United Kingdom to try and
persuade us to remain now in that
leaflet in the last page it says very
clearly this is a once in a generation
decision and it then said I can remember
the words literally it says this is your
decision the government will implement
what you decide well the people decided
decided that the government didn't
implement it hence the division and the
frustration in our country if the
government had done what the people
having given them the choice having
promised them that they would implement
their decision when the people decided
many people in government didn't like
thought it was the wrong answer if they
had implemented the decision as they
promised in the booklets they promised
every elector in the United Kingdom we
wouldn't be in this it was it who said
if a democracy can't change its mind
it's not a democracy do you remember who
said
Church oh it was David Davis more
recently I'm sorry in 2012 he said it in
a speech I thought too one said
something in all those times but anyway
anyway this would have been more recent
2012 undoubtedly that's a promise that
people can change their minds why can't
they change them minds over brexit you
change your mind over the whole time
over what leader you've got well I
haven't what government with respect so
I haven't changed my mind they've a
brexit you the Conservatives well look
the people voted they took a decision
they didn't change their mind well we've
taken a decision in Parliament we spent
40 years in the House of Commons arguing
about Europe almost really from the day
that we joined the European Economic
Community in 1973 in the end we agreed
on one thing which is that we couldn't
agree so we all agreed or nearly
everybody overwhelmingly the House of
Commons voted to put the decision to the
British people in a referendum I think
from memory over 500 MPs voted for that
all there abouts so the House of Commons
overwhelmingly said let's put it to the
people and everybody promised faithfully
to abide by the result now you could
argue a cynic might have thought that's
just both sides thought they were gonna
win but anyway everybody promised and
the decision was to leave and yet many
people in the House of Commons never
accepted it felt it was the wrong answer
felt the people had made a dreadful
mistake and have spent the last three
years digging there who was he doing
everything they can to frustrate the
will of the people this as I said as you
quoted me this is more from Lee versus
remain to the people versus the
establishment and in the end in a
democracy the people must prevail mr.
France why you took issue when I said
you were reveling in the divisions in
the country but you like to pick out
targets to have a go at Angie when the
German boss of Airbus Tom Enders said
brexit ears were mad to say his company
would never leave the UK because the
Airbus has huge factories there you let
him have it with both barrels didn't you
accused him of Teutonic arrogance and
they started talking about your father a
deed a veteran who never submitted to
bullying by any German
his son you said what others mr. Anders
got to do with the war and your father
on d-day well mr. Evans has now been
replaced to airbus by game fooi who said
at a press conference i think two weeks
ago that airbus whatever happened on
brexit will now remain in the United
Kingdom and were committed to the United
so he has a different view yes but at
the time you've said it what did mr.
Enders have to do well your father
indeed well mr. Enders by his by
threatening to withdraw 14,000 jobs from
the United Kingdom was effectively
trying to bully British members of
parliament in how to vote in the House
of Commons what he was pointing out that
if you took certain political decisions
in this country there'll be consequences
for his company well those consequences
appear to have changed because the new
chief executive of Airbus who is should
we say not as aggressive as mr. Enders
in his character there's now assured us
that airbus are here for the long term
aggressive about him taking seriously
his responsibility for the thousands of
workers Airbus employs in the UK well he
was threatening to take away their jobs
that's how seriously he took these
responsibilities he was warning them
that the jobs were in danger he wasn't
threatening to take the world he was
warning the jobs were in danger well it
would appear the new CEO says they're
not you think people would say mr. mr.
Francois was tough here he stuck it to
the Germans is what did you want to come
out of this extraordinary exchange would
you prefer I don't think any any company
be they British or European or American
or Brazilian or Chinese be they Holloway
or anybody else should attempt to bully
the house of course Donald Trump
attempts to bully you said any any
political leader no I said any company
ah but you're meek as a lamb where
Donald Trump is conceived
if you comes in I think comes Italy says
whatever I don't mean I don't mean to
challenge your skill as an interviewer
but if you are going to quote me quietly
properly about what I didn't say that
about Donald Trump because he's not a
company okay so why are you so silent
when he comes in he he insults the Mayor
of London the duchess of sussex
he tells the government what to do
he endorses Boris Johnson as leader and
you're quite happy about that to be
bullied by America
well silent about that oh wait one
second I thought we were talking about
brexit we are we're talking about
divisions as well we're talking about
your attitude to people telling Britain
as you say or trying to bully Britain
that's what well so I thought we were
talking about company that had attempted
to bully the House of Commons yeah and
now we're talking about the leader
attempting to bully her house
governments well okay Donald Trump is
not a company he's an elected I
understand now
he is the President of the United States
now some people don't like him but he
was democratically elected by the
American people he holds that office
because he won a presidential election
in the United States now he's not
everybody's cup of tea
he's extremely plain speaking some
people don't like that on the plain
speaking politician so I I'm not
frightened of that but he has engaged in
a direct flagrant attempt to influence
British politics well for instance you
wouldn't accept this from any European
leaders well well for instance he has
been involved in a debate about whether
or not we should allow the Chinese
company Holly
access to our telecommunications network
when we grow a 5g network in this
country personally I think he's right
that the National Security Council as we
now know were divided on the issue some
secretaries of state thought that it was
acceptable and we could manage the risk
other secretaries of state thought that
we couldn't manage the risk and it was
far too dangerous but it's threatening
Britain that if it doesn't make the
right decision over that's bullying well
well wait one second I think what he
said and again maybe you might want to
interview him about it but I think he's
cautioning us against what he believes
is not a wise course of action because
of intelligence sharing between the
so-called five eyes community ourselves
the United States Australia Canada and
New Zealand is fundamental to the
national security of all five of us and
indeed to the west but my point is you
accept the kind of bullying from Donald
Trump that you wouldn't accept from in a
year
well the president in the early States
has a view and he's come over here and
he tends to review well Anwar why I
think he's right so as always he's right
you're happy to accept well from abroad
I don't think him commenting on far away
is bullying let's talk about Jeremy
Corbyn you've got three minutes to talk
about whatever you was talking about
Jeremy called me in April you called him
a Marxist with anti-semitic tendencies
if he is a Marxist so what he happens to
be an elected leader of Her Majesty's
loyal opposition here why does that rule
him out as an interlocutor for your
party because you complained that to
resume shouldn't sat down and spoke
Jeremy Corbyn is not just a Marxist he
has presided over a culture of
anti-semitism within the Labour Party
which is now being investigated by the
Human Rights Commission not by me well
wait one second
he is a Republican has been all his life
doesn't hide it doesn't like the
monarchy he also is a lifelong member of
the campaign for nuclear disarmament
he is always passionately believed in
reducing our nuclear polishing and
nuclear defenses he's been my Achilles
antithetical to everything my party
believes why should we get into bed with
a man who represents everything we
detest so what you've said in effect is
that jeremy corbyn's political beliefs
whatever they may be have put him beyond
the pale and ruled him out as a
political interlocutor that's a
dangerous idea in a democracy isn't it
no I'll only talk to the people whose
views you like well accord with her with
respect we talk to other politicians all
the time in the House of Commons but
you're drawing a line I would a little I
wouldn't do a deal over the future of
this country with that man no never mind
the fact that he is freely and fairly
elected they've chosen him to be their
leader doesn't mean I have to agree with
him I think he'd be a disastrous Prime
Minister and I hope and believe he will
never be the Prime Minister of the
United but your efforts the efforts of
the Conservative Party may well put him
in the top slot
Wells you alright how will you think
then of what you've done well I don't
believe Jeremy Coleman will win a
general election because I don't believe
the British people want to vote for a
Marxist when anti-semitic Lee you're not
necessarily the best clairvoyant well if
it's an election the really important
thing about that is you won't decide and
neither will I the people will it's
called democracy thank you for your time
thank you very much indeed
[Music]
you